do you know that you and I went on a
vacation together
we went to the Bahamas
leave Shriver was on the plane oh yeah
and uh Fergie sang oh my gosh
um okay uh that was really fun
I have a really weird back story to that
trip that I just I oh my God telling her
enough I like I yeah I got too drunk on
that flight and I was like horrified and
I it was like so embarrassing it's like
a tiny plane almost got all the bombs it
was awful God I mean it's fun but I'm so
like mortified I might have changed my
life a lot since that flight
okay well I mentioned that you had
directed like the church choir you were
in when you were 11 months old 11 months
by the way I was 11 months old when I
started 11 years old and like how what
was like the moment that like you'd even
discovered you could sing do you
remember where you were well my
grandmother sings or sang and uh my mom
sings and so we were just all singing
all the time and then I was starting to
play the piano at a very young age and
the minister of Music there quit and so
I just started directing it but like
trying to tell adults what to do when
you're 11 not so much they were not
having it but you did it but I did it
and they sounded good too
I mean you must have been really proud
of yourself I'm very proud of myself
um okay
um I I hear we're both single you're
single oh yeah
I haven't dated you single really you
think so yeah I well thank you do you
want to be dating are you dating I go on
dates
I do I go on dates what is it like for
you right now well the truth is I was in
a 10-year relationship and it ended last
August and it's really hard like prying
your energy apart from someone and
realizing what is your own before you
went into the relationship and what are
you left with and so what is it like
it's been very difficult
um but Illuminating eye-opening and
I think we're both better we love each
other me and my ex partner he's he's a
lovely man and we learn a lot from each
other
um but our time you know expired and we
move on do you do you like dating I find
it to be incredibly um uncomfortable uh
it's um I haven't done it in so long
like what makes you uncomfortable about
it I don't really care about
what people think and for like an hour
or however long the dinner is I'm
supposed to sit and pretend to be
interested and I know that's it defeats
the purpose because you want to like be
interested in the person you're going to
date right but if you're not
overwhelmingly a thinker or
compassionate or if you don't like dogs
then it's going to be over right you
know okay so what would you if you were
to enter another dating phase or a
relationship what would you be looking
for
well
you have to be compassionate and care
about the world uh you have to
have something that you're focused on
your own career I can't miss anyone's
world if you don't work we don't work
that's my motto oh yeah oil right keep
it yeah
try it on yeah yeah
um what else I think and they got to be
able to cook or at least love to eat
what I'm cooking and they have to be
really funny okay so if you find them
bring them to me I wouldn't don't get me
involved in your date because I will get
involved in your dating life for some
reason I'm better with others than my
own I think that's what everybody's
everything of course I can't believe
we're having this conversation
I'm here to talk about Shamika Dune
let's talk about schmegado oh yes
you're the narrator this season this is
the second season this is a great show a
total hit
um how is this season for you it is so
good single Paul wrote the hell out of
this season it's such a love letter to
musical theater
and it has so many twists and turns and
I get to be really dark and salacious
and it's really satisfying it was
satisfying to film I hope it's
satisfying to watch well actually we
have a clip here
[Applause]
rotting
why did you do it I I didn't
aren't you omniscient
Am I who knows
I mean this show is such a hit it is so
much fun and it has such a stellar cast
by the way I heard you're a fan of
Easter yes you are my favorite holidays
really yeah well we you Easter it up
with me yes I have a little uh Garden we
can go to let's go all right
thank you
[Music]